o dia estava indo para a praia com as
amigas minhas
e uma delas que também é em outubro
falou assim a menina voltou com uma
espinha gigante na minha bunda agente
conversou sobre aquilo que decidimos que
a espinha na bunda nenhuma e acabar com
nossa viagem
a gente ia para a praia curtir entrar no
mar é como o frango à passarinho
e de fato foi o que a gente fez a gente
chegou lá e curtiu e aí lá a gente
decidiu gravar um vídeo sobre isso né
o que é preciso para ter o corpo
perfeito para curtir o verão
se você for an nas bancas ou serviço se
dão um script certinho dieta detox
grafite crossfit dieta detox morrer
nasceu de novo né vai ficar me parece
que você não se você não tivesse corpo
perfeito você não tem direito de curtir
o verão né
mas nada disso é verdade gente a gente
incomoda com essas coisinhas pequenas e
na verdade pra curtir o verão o que a
gente precisa fazer é ter um corpo e
querer curtir o verão não é verdade
eu reparei que as meninas elas não vão à
praia ela não vai parar por vergonha do
corpo na verdade eu vou ter que revelar
quem era o youtube era de útil pela
troca
ela estava com espera bunda a gente
lançou o vídeo foi um sucesso bongô e
lendo os comentários do vídeo mais de
60% e isso foi muito triste mas 60%
aqueles comentários eram de meninas
falando gente eu não vou à praia há dez
anos por vergonha do meu corpo ou
meninas falando meninas brigada por esse
vídeo porque eu odeio o meu corpo ou
meninas falando eu não vou à praia
porque as pessoas riem de mim
ou seja as mulheres estão deixando de
viver a vida de ser feliz por vergonha
do corpo
isso é inadmissível eu estava dando uma
palestra em são paulo este mês uma
menina falou pra mim
jéssica
eu não dou tchau causa da gordura do
braço
então você chega no rio ela foi embora
continua lá inclusive o ataque hoje
busca do resultado
tudo aqui ajudou além dos comentários do
vídeo desse vídeo sobre corpo perfeito
eu tive a idéia de criar esse outro
canal e atividade eu vi que a gente
precisava muito falar sobre isso a gente
ainda precisa avançar muito nesse debate
aí eu tive a idéia de criar o canal
gorda de boa porque tem gente que é
magro de ruim eu sou uma gorda de boa e
aí gente
eu reparei que na verdade não precisava
desse estardalhaço todo não precisava
criar um canal no youtube
eu não precisava de milhares de
seguidoras de comentários pra ver que
isso realmente é um problema sério
porque quando fui reparar no meu íntimo
no meu íntimo mesmo as três mulheres
mais importantes da minha vida minha mãe
minha irmã e minha melhor amiga
as três se acham feias porque né
quem botou isso na cabeça delas
provavelmente quem botou isso na cabeça
delas foi uma pessoa que fez uma imagem
pensando nessa conversa que a gente está
tendo hoje eu fui buscar no google o
termo mulher perfeita
quando eu joguei mulher perfeita no
google a primeira imagem que aparece é o
seguinte a mulher perfeita
engraçado é triste triste se separam que
não é só uma questão da minha irmã da
minha mãe não é só uma questão da da
menina com aspirina boom da menina que
não dá tchau
é uma questão de todas as mulheres não é
nenhuma mulher se acha bonita nenhuma
mulher acredita que esse noite pra gente
com esse cara é essa pessoa que pensa
assim
a gente não pode cair nessa armadilha né
essa pessoa ainda acha que mulher a
mercadoria né que é um pedaço de carne
que é uma cidadã de segunda classe ea
gente é muito mais que isso
muito mais que isso continuando na
internet é que é onde eu atuo apareceu
magicamente natalino do meu facebook é o
seguinte matéria quando eu li eu falei
eu vou a marca matéria dessas liberdades
lindas e que possui um defeitinho no
corpo
falei eu vou ter que falar sobre isso
gente
quando eu abrir a matéria eu me deparei
chocada fiquei com ela
kate middleton que segundo a matéria é
uma mulher super defeituoso por causa eu
sei que eu não falasse vocês não reparar
por causa dessa cicatriz de três
centímetros que ela tem na cabeça
é gente é chocante as pessoas escrevem
sobre isso eu também fiquei muito
chocada quando a segunda lista quem
rihanna por causa de quê espinha
mas que já se estão vendo isso aqui nem
eu que quando se olha para rihanna
senhora tem gente cobrando é tão
maravilhoso que esquece de st
outra coisa que me chocou foi a que
tinha direito robert sabe sobre o que
ele estava falando de roberts suas
obturações juro não tô mentindo
isso é bom né porque é sinal que ela é
feliz na rota é né mostra a obturação
mesmo eu fiquei pensando foi gente
resolveu dentista então só saúde bucal
né não é motivo de defeito né
e uma coisa que me chocou muito e que é
assim uma questão do tablóide americano
que acompanha sabe que existem matérias
em matérias as pessoas escrevem sobre
isso é o dedão da megan fox sempre que
os dois realmente eu não mostrar a vocês
não perceber que tem de errado com o
dedão dela nada absolutamente nada as
pessoas continuam falando por aí gente
a noite se separaram que todas essas
mulheres que eu citei elas são o padrão
de beleza
quando a gente não as mulheres normais
meras mortais agente mira num padrão uma
mulher que a gente acha que a gente mora
nelas e nem elas estão perfeitas para o
padrão elas são podemos fazer mas nem
assim segue padrão existe mesmo
será que a gente realmente deve levar
esse padrão em conta
sabe quando eu parei de me importar com
o xingamento insulto à gente querendo
fazer o meu
já por ser quem eu sou quando reparei
que as pessoas criticam
ivete sangalo se uma pessoa tem a
capacidade crítica à ivete sangalo quem
já está na fila do pão né
o que a pessoa tem capacidade
achar alguma coisa da ivete sangalo vai
estar em qualquer uma de nós aliás boca
tirar um pouquinho desse momento só pra
pensar vai dizendo que só de falar e vai
adicionar já me sinto melhor é tão
maravilhosa e uma energia assim é que te
faz bem né
ela é maravilhosa as pessoas criticam
inverte
eu vou contar pra vocês eu sei muito bem
como é perigoso não está dentro do
padrão nem triste é perigoso mesmo
porque quando eu tinha 13 anos e estava
na escola
naquela época você começa a reparar os
menininhos comecei a entender a sua
sexualidade
eu reparei muito também só quero uma
menininha
eu me apaixonei por uma menina e eu
sempre fui muito cristã
eu entrei em depressão que na igreja
escutava eu fazia parte do grupo de
jovem atuava na igreja e na igreja quer
um lugar que eu amava eu amo até hoje eu
escutava que aquilo era um pecado e que
eu era uma abominação uma menina de 13
anos
eu fiquei dois anos o prazo de dois anos
da adolescência com depressão e síndrome
do pânico
foi realmente um período de trevas e
quando eu estava na faculdade
e aí eu já estava bem já tinha aceitado
minha sexualidade eu toquei com isso
chegou a hora de fazer o tcc e eu não
conseguia tirar aquilo na minha cabeça
que é muito sofrimento
eu falei acho que vou criar alguma coisa
para tentar ajudar outras possíveis
jéssica de 13 anos que estejam passando
pelo mesmo que eu passei
e daí surgiu o canal 2 bi no canal da
sbe de fato hoje em dia a gente atende
vários jovens lgbt os brasileiros
diariamente a gente lida com casos de
agressão violência expulsão de casa
cárcere privado depressão suicídio
percebem como é perigoso não está no
padrão
o padrão padrão padrão comecei a surtar
nessa palavra a a at&t havoc agora né
mas foi bom foi bom em poderá daqui nem
vete comecei a pensar sobre o padrão
fui pesquisar a origem da palavra e ela
vem do latim patronos e é muito louco
porque patronos da origem a outra
palavra também patrão o que significa
manda você tem que fazer e tira a
liberdade do seu patrão na casa mas eu
acho sinceramente que chegou a hora da
gente parar de aceitar a ordem entendeu
a gente tem que começar a fazer uma
greve vamos organizar um sindicato na
parada
eu como membro dessa revolução eo
decreto que a partir de agora a gente
não vai mais seguir esse padrão de
beleza e não alcançava o único padrão
que a gente vai seguir a partir de agora
o padrão da felicidade é o padrão da
felicidade porque ninguém nada tem o
direito de acabar com o nosso amor
próprio
na verdade nada têm esse direito porque
o que tem de menina triste se odiando
impressão como eu estive sem sair de
casa sem a praia sem da tctau não está
no livro é que a gente pára de se esse
padrão é alcançável de beleza e começa a
seguir o padrão da felicidade
eu explico é fácil eu tenho respostas
são três passos muito simples o primeiro
para admirar a revista mira no espelho
só que você
não é uma competição gente não tem
prêmio no final
vendam nova gincana você não tem que ser
mais bonita que ninguém
a gente não tem que competir você não
tem que ser tão bonita quanto alguém
você tem que ser bonita pra você mesma
cindy crawford 2014 já foi capa de
revista de assim todas as revistas do
mundo já que ela disse uma vez abre
aspas
eu também queria aparecer assim croft
assim como todas aquelas outras seis
entendem que nem elas são aquilo isso
essa sim de qual for ela é montada a
base de muita maquiagem muito photoshop
nem sabem disso
uma equipe de 30 pessoas portais ea
gente né eu tenho nenhuma pergunta você
está aqui não deixa essa sorte mesmo
a gente já repararam que a gente sempre
quer emagrecer mais cinco quilos
a gente sempre precisa fazer a
sobrancelha e sempre precisa porque
preciso de um silicone ou de uma lipo
a gente nunca está satisfeito nunca a
gente nunca pode falar nunca a gente
sempre está em busca dessa perfeição
essa coisa perfeita perfeita perfeita
a gente vai se tocar que aquele
defeitinho na verdade não é defeito é só
mais uma parte do nosso corpo
só mais uma parte de quem a gente é
perfeição fiquei que nem o padrão na
bola fiquei assim se pesquisar
fui ler a palavra perfeito e vem do
latim que eu tô super latina
perfect que significa e rompem os
tambores completo completo diz entender
que é muito mais uma questão de bem
estar e de autonomia de aceitação do que
realmente estética e beleza de visual
eu por exemplo eu podia ser magra eu
podia ser loira mas será que é ser feliz
será que não ia querer ser mais magra
será que ele vai querer ser mais loira é
que não tenho o direito de me olhar no
espelho falatório homens e jéssica
relegou do mês ela é ótima e aí você vai
me dizer mas jessica está lindo de novo
só que é difícil eu não consigo gostar
da minha celulite não consigo aceitar a
mestria
não tem jeito não eu acabo com você
nesse momento das nossas vidas
você consegue ver beleza na imperfeição
do outro
já repararam nisso a gente vê beleza nem
perfeito pra [ __ ]
citando um par que é o dono de uma folha
aceita que eu piso naquela hora por
barulho que você faz se acha linda tirar
photofiltre panetta achou realmente
bonito aquela folha ea folha está
morrendo vem
não é pra ser bonito é triste que o meu
não é bonito mas a gente acha bonito que
é um perfeito também bonito uma amiga
sua
chega e você pergunta assim uma amiga
fora do padrão tá amiga gorda uma amiga
que você pergunta se a amiga tão bonita
hoje e você responde está eu tenho
certeza que vocês falam do fundo do
coração de vocês porque vocês realmente
acham que é amigo de vocês está bonito
que você consegue achar sua amiga bonita
você consegue ver beleza nem perfeito da
sua amiga e não no seu país deve
investir nessa palestra agora por
exemplo pensando já está linda né
eu não estou nada dentro do padrão vamos
combinar que vocês conseguem ver beleza
no meu imperfeito e não de vocês porque
eu completo
uma das coisas que acho mais bonitas do
mundo ela é super imperfeita super
assimétrica com esse tamanho até do
outro é perfeito
eu acho que é super prefeito entende que
leva a gente é um segundo passo é
reconhecer os nossos privilégios
eu tenho uma doença de pele muito rara e
grave genética e se chama idéia de
emitir superativa dá pra ver algumas
lesões por aqui eu tenho no corpo
inteiro é uma doença que me dá muita dor
que eu fico muito de cama por causa dela
e uma vez eu estava indo pro hospital no
com muita dor e eu estava assim chegando
deus do mundo estava muito triste estou
muito mal então me sentindo péssima
porque comigo porque porque eu tenho que
sentir tanta dor porque eu tenho que ter
24 anos e tem que as pessoas têm que me
dar banho eu não consigo fazer nada
sozinha porque eu vivo assim o que eu
fiz eu realmente me odiando demais
aquele dia eu te amo minha vida quando
eu cheguei lá no hospital eu estava na
sala de medicação e entra um velhinho
ele estava honrando de dor estava com um
problema no nervo que não sei qual é
em primeiro ficou tão desesperada que
perguntou pra ele como o senhor veio
respondeu de ônibus
eu tinha ido de carro com ar
condicionado no maior conforto do mundo
às vezes a gente acha que a gente está
na pior que a gente egoísta o suficiente
para não perceber que tem gente que tem
mais dificuldade que a gente a gente é
tão prepotente mas tão prepotente que a
gente não consegue ver com sortudo a
gente é extensão elite na perna
você tem uma perna
tem vergonha da pré-época do corpo
você pode aparecer nu na cama né como eu
já estive muito de cama
eu dou muito valor para o meu corpo a
doença fez enxergar meu corpo de uma
maneira diferente
eu amo o meu corpo mas eu amo muito meu
corpo porque eu sei como é não ter
funcionando bem
eu valorizo coisas como acordar me
espreguiçar de manhã consegui tomar
banho sozinha conseguir pôr o meu
próprio almoço fazer isso que estou
fazendo aqui ó que há dois meses atrás
eu não estava conseguindo durante uma
crise andar que nos leva ao nosso
terceiro e último passo
a troca entre mulheres vão achando que
eu só desconstruir dona do rolê na hora
eu tive a ajuda de muita mulher para
chegar até aqui muita mulher foram elas
que me ensinaram tudo isso foi batendo e
conversando com elas eu tirei esse esse
cabresto do do padrão de beleza e
consegui me amar
talvez se não fosse por ele não estaria
aqui hoje
muita gente me pergunta assim mas
jéssica quando você consegue a matando
seu corpo e valorizar a ponto de ensinar
para as outras meninas
e aí eu sempre respondo não sou eu
somos nós então não vamos deixar isso
pede essa conversa morrer aqui conversa
com suas mães conversam com suas irmãs
conversa com suas melhores amigas assim
como eu faço com aquelas três conversa
eu sei que é difícil eu sei que dói eu
sei que machuca porque porque o tempo
todo falando pra gente o que você é feia
você fez você fez efeito não é fácil dói
pelos trabalhos que eu faço na internet
com os dois canais
eu sou lembrada de área mente do quanto
foi rodeada pelo mundo
é o tempo todo corda feio horrorosa
morre mas o que esses hits
eles retornam a partir de hoje o chamado
de patrão
o que estes patrões que os patrões
vizinhos não imaginam é que eu já
entendi a parada eu já entendi lance não
é jéssica
claro que incomoda muito mais por seguro
claro que incomoda muito mais por ser
lésbica
taís araújo incomoda muito mais por ser
negra uma mulher transexual incomodar
mais por ser mulher transexual a gente
incomoda mais por ser minoria porque a
mais fora do padrão
mas eles também falam da julia roberts
eles também falam da megan fox
o lance com ele são todas as mulheres
somos nós
não é pessoal não sou eu não é você que
não é feita e eles vão tentar o tempo
todo fazer você não acreditar no que eu
vou falar agora
talvez você possa até ainda não
acreditar mas você é perfeita e
imperfeita como ivete sangalo
obrigado